مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الى موجز الانباء من
قناه الجزيره
تنطلق بعد ساعات في قطر بطوله كاس العالم
2022 التي تستمر حتى الثامن عشر من الشهر
المقبل لتكون اول مونديال ينظم في دوله
عربيه او مسلمه ومع استكمال للاستعدادات
اكدت قطر والفيفا ان هذه النسخه ستكون
تاريخيه واستثنائيه على مستوى المنشات
والجوانب التنظيميه وظروف اجراء المباريات
مع التقنيات وخدمات سيتم استخدامها لاول
مره في تاريخ كاس العالم لكره القدم
استن كده رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
جيني انفانتينو الانتقادات المتعلقه بكاس
العالم والتي وصفها بالدروس الاخلاقيه
التي تنم عن النفاق وقال انفانتينو ان على
الاوروبيين الاعتذار عن ما فعلوه في
العالم خلال ثلاثه الاف سنه الماضيه قبل
اعطاء دروس في الاخلاق واكد انفانتينو
جاهزيه قطر التامه لاستضافه ما وصفها
بافضل بطوله لكاس العالم وتوفير اجواء
امنه للجماهير
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التركيه تنفيذ
مقاتلتها لغارات في ساعه متاخره من مسائي
امس السبت على معاقل ما وصفتها بتنظيمات
الارهابيه الشماليه سوريا والعراق في اطار
ما سمتها عمليه المخلب السيف
وقالت الوزاره ان العمليه تاتي في اطار
القصاص لما وصفته بالهجوم الغادر في اشاره
الى الانفجار الذي وقع الاسبوع الماضي في
اسطنبول وادى الى سقوط قتلى وجرحى
انتقل رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشنس هناك
الرئيس الاوكراني في الاردن
هناك على استمرار الدعم البريطاني
لاوكرانيا لمواجهه حرب روسيا عليها
وتعاهد بمزيد من الاسلحه بينها انظمه دفاع
جوي
كبير المساعدين الرئيس الاوكراني في
الاردن
الا عندما يتم تدمير الجيش الروسي وتستعيد
اوكرانيا حدود عام
1991 التي تشمل المقاطعات الاوكرانيه
الاربعه التي اعلنت روسيا ضمها من جانب
واحد الى جانب شبه جزيره القرد
قال رئيس لجنه الشؤون الدوليه في مجلس
الدومه الروسيه بلاده لم تغلق باب التفاوض
مع اوكرانيا ولا ترفض مواصله المفاوضات
وتهم المسؤول الروسي الرئيس الاوكراني
بمحاوله جر نيته الى صراع مع روسيا بعد
حادث سقوط صاروخ في بولندا
لا يريد قطيعه كامله مع روسيا
اتفقت دول المشاركه في مؤتمر الامم
المتحده للمناخ كوب 27 بالاجماع على اتفاق
شامل لمواجهه التغيرات المناخيه وخفض
الانبعاثات الكربونيه بشكل سريع وذلك في
جلسه عامه ختاميه في منتجع شرم الشيخ في
مصر
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء